The darker side of chocolate has some surprising health benefits.
Its impressive antioxidant powers...
...fight free radicals better than almost any other food,...
...almost eight times that of a strawberry.
These same flavanols can stimulate the lining of arteries,...
...allowing them to relax and increase blood flow and reduce blood pressure.
It can also inhibit bad cholesterol and increases your good cholesterol, HDL...
...and can help prevent heart disease and diabetes.
A one ounce serving size of delicious dark chocolate...
...has a surprising amount of fiber, vitamins and minerals.
The bioactive compounds of dark chocolate may also protect against sun damage,...
...improve blood flow to the skin, increase skin density and hydration.
In one study, it doubled the body's tolerance to sun exposure.
While these health benefits are certainly very exciting,...
...it's important to keep things in moderation.
Savoring a small one-inch piece of high quality dark chocolate per night...
...is probably about right.
And remember that you should be aiming for over 70% cacao in your dark chocolate.
And the higher the percentage, the better.